This video is sponsored by Skillshare.
The first 500 people to use the link in the
description get their first two months free.
If you’ve ever made something, a song, painting,
story, or, the pinnacle of artistic expression,
a YouTube video, you know it’s incredibly
fun, and, well, pretty strange,
because creativity is kind-of a mysterious
black box.
Some days, you’re flooded with ideas faster
than you can write them down,
other times your brain just feels empty.
It can feel less like a skill and more like
the weather, coming and going, only somewhat
predictably.
which, kinda… sucks, How do you ever get
better?
You want a recipe, a guide, just some indication
you’re on the path to eventual improvement.
So, what do you do?
Well, if you want to improve your golf swing,
you ask an experienced golfer.
Find the best musician, artist, actor, writer
and ask: To what do you attribute your success?
The problem is being good at something doesn’t
make you aware of why, or good at explaining
it.
These are two separate skills.
We’ve all had that brilliant professor who
just can’t teach.
So, they very often have no idea.
Worse, they’re absolutely convinced they
do.
People love a good story.
They’ll turn a string of lucky circumstances
into an exciting drama about overcoming challenges,
wrap it in a neat little bow, maybe sell it
as an expensive dead tree.
Famous people are, well, famous for giving
advice like “Just be yourself”, or “Follow
your dreams and good things will come”.
Very profound, and, totally meaningless.
There aren’t many Bo Burnhams out there:
“don’t take advice from people like me
who have gotten very lucky.
We’re very biased.
You know, like Taylor Swift telling you to
follow your dreams is like a lottery winner
telling you, ‘Liquidize your assets, buy
Powerball tickets, it works!”
Famous actors and CEOs are weird outliers,
Their stories get the most attention… and
they’re the least useful.
So, how do you get better?
We need a way of understanding creativity,
Not how to sketch landscapes, or write plot
twists, but how to get better at, well, getting
better
This is Ira Glass. You might recognize his voice:
He’s host of the incredibly popular radio
show This American Life, creators of Serial
and S-Town.
If there’s such thing as a Blockbuster Podcast,
these are them.
And, a while back, he gave a talk at my school.
But what surprised me is how much of what
he said applies to making… anything.
He’s been doing radio for 30 years, but
it doesn’t matter if you’re writing, drawing,
acting, or editing, creativity is largely
the same.
"All of us who do creative work … we get
into it because we have good taste.
But it’s like there’s a gap
what you’re making isn’t so good.
But your taste — your taste is still killer,
and your taste is good enough that you can
tell that what you’re making is kind of
a disappointment to you."
If this is the process of getting better,
The good news is that everyone starts here,
days, weeks, months go by with little progress,
Want proof?
Go back and watch a YouTube channel’s first
videos, just, please not mine.
But progress is exponential, As you improve,
you also get better at getting better.
It just takes time and practice, ideally some
instruction.
In other words, take more photos, make more
videos, and you’ll eventually get better.
But if that’s really all it takes, why do
so few people get past this phase?
Well, because “just keep making things”
may be true, but it’s not really great advice,
at least not by itself.
You might get better, or, you might make the
same mistakes over and over again,
Month after month, year after year, nothing
will happen.
Because there is one necessary ingredient
- taste, awareness, the desire to make better
stuff and the knowledge that you aren’t
there yet.
The gap is the difference between what you
can make and what you wish you could make.
You might say - but isn’t awareness of your
skill, itself a skill?
Unfortunately, yes.
And that’s why it’s so easy to repeat
the same mistakes, you don’t know there
is a mistake.
When the gap is too small, your skill too
close to your expectations, you won’t improve,
When it’s too big, you’ll give up.
Only a tiny goldilocks zone can sustain creativity
long enough to get you to the exponential
curve of improvement.
And, early on, satisfaction with your work
is entirely artificial - you’re smiling
at garbage - but that’s how you get past
the necessary, mundane phase of gaining momentum.
But there is one problem with this theory,
if improvement is exponential, why doesn’t
it always last?
If this were true, people and companies would
eventually gain so much momentum they couldn’t
be stopped.
And yet they clearly come and go.
and that’s because the gap naturally shrinks
over time, you get better at judging your
own work, and you get comfortable.
This is the plateau of progress, The reason
even the biggest companies in the world have
to stay on guard,
Companies like Google and Apple operate with
remarkable efficiency,
they’re so big it’s hard to imagine them
ever failing.
But that efficiency is also their biggest
threat - as they gain momentum, it’s also
harder to turn, harder to adapt.
Even if, way back in 2000, you predicted the
rise of streaming video and the fall of movie
rentals, You might still bet on Blockbuster
- Sure, their business will change, but they
can adapt with far more resources and efficiency
than a brand new company.
So, what happened?
They hit a plateau of progress, they stopped
innovating.
Management was just too satisfied,
When Blockbuster was way over here, Netflix
was barely here, and now, well… yeah.
Which proves the power of a well-positioned
gap of motivated dissatisfaction,
and that it’s never too late for a newcomer
to learn quickly and rise exponentially.
Even on YouTube, there’s so much room for
new creators.
In fact, I very much encourage them.
Which is why I’m happy to announce my own
course, How to Make an Animated YouTube Video,
with today’s sponsor, Skillshare.
You can learn how I make these videos and
how you can too.
It’s broken down into ten, short, animated
video lessons -
Everything from choosing topics to researching,
writing scripts, and animating.
I go over my organization method, the apps
I use, and specific techniques.
Plus, you can post questions, get feedback,
and I’ve included some practice files you
can easily download and get started with.
It’s one of thousands of classes on Skillshare,
with other topics like art, writing, business,
and photography.
And a premium membership gives you unlimited
access to all of them.
But the first 500 people to use the link in
the description get 2 months free, so you
can watch my course and any number of others
at absolutely no cost.
Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this show,
and to you for listening.